as many people are looking forward to
traveling for the holidays safety should
be top of Mind before you leave and
securing your home is easier than you
think Jonathan Alvarez with Crime
Stoppers of Southern Nevada and CEO of
protective Force International sees a
spike in burglaries around the holidays
he says convenience is key for thieves
so don't make it easy for them investing
in good lighting throughout your house
will not only assist with the camera
systems if you have them but it also
deters a lot of criminal activity
another option is using inexpensive
lighting that is solar powered homeowner
Cindy Kester keeps her windows locked
sealed and covered so no one can peek
inside for the garage doors set it so
nobody can go by and open it so there's
always a little switch that you can turn
it off and that way nobody else can use
their remote to open up your garage door
I do this every night both Kester and
Alvarez agree you should also get to
know your neighbors so you can watch out
for each other also be careful of what
you post on social media yeah some key
advice from experts it's important to
hide and spread out your jewelry and
important documents instead of keeping
it all in one place Mary Jane beliesza 8
News Now